hundreds of Palestinians are clashing
this morning with Israeli forces in the
West Bank the protests are part of a
so-called Day of Rage over president
Trump's decision to recognize Jerusalem
as Israel's capital demonstrations have
stretched from Chicago to Gaza and from
Jordan to Pakistan Seth Doane is in the
West Bank city of Ramallah not far from
Jerusalem amid the Palestinian protests
Seth goodmorning goodmorning Friday
prayers are now over and the protests
here in Ramallah have already begun you
can see Palestinians have lit some tires
on fire behind me just down the road
they are throwing rocks toward Israeli
forces who are further down the road you
can see them in their helmets and they
are occasionally returning fire of tear
gas and rubber bullets today Palestinian
protesters again clashed with Israeli
security forces they're furious with the
u.s. for in their view unilaterally
siding with Israel bracing for violence
hundreds of additional Israeli security
reinforcements were deployed early this
morning while the faithful of all ages
including young men were allowed into
the al-aqsa mosque in Jerusalem's Old
City it's one of the holiest sites for
Muslims and is at the heart of the
controversy over President Trump's
decision across the region protesters
filled streets in Egypt Jordan and in
Turkey where signs read Jerusalem
belongs to Islam in Pakistan they lit
both the US and Israeli flags on fire
clashes with police sparked earlier in
the week we were in Bethlehem for those
now there's okay now project projectiles
have just been thrown in our direction
we're moving back that's where we met 21
year old University student nasara come
see up among the protesters who no
longer see the US is qualified to be a
mediator looking forward that the
America is is the country that will make
peace here this is how we used to look
at America but Jerusalem's mayor near
bar khat told us he thought president
Trump's change of policy
ultimately bring peace he is keeping his
promise in the campaign and for us in
Jerusalem it's a major important
milestone Hamas the powerful Islamic
group in control of the Gaza Strip has
called for a new Intifada or Palestinian
uprising the question Nora is will the
violence continue and expand past this
day of rage all right Seth Doane in the
West Bank thank you